welcome to the Deshawn MIDI your hole
subscribe if you haven't already my next
guest we're going to be talking about
one of the most famous woman in the
world round Rousey and someone who's
been at the top the most talked about
the most famous but why would someone
like that be contemplating suicide all
this and more on this week's show
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
you know this is the Salam alaikum peace
be with you
Salam what happened to LA Livia how you
been honey LA very well very well
you are coming in from Wisconsin yes
making the murderer have you heard of
the documentary on comentary yes what's
da wrong he's your neighbor no he's not
he's about an hour so away so you know
he's my neighbor didn't you know the
same as you guys are as well okay that's
quite out there how you been what's new
since the last time we met up well
there's a lot of stuff going on me we're
named in an election cycle so that's
obviously no one going on and people to
get a pounder with that daily a lot of
stuff going on across very
matter-of-fact in Indiana just hearing
about the three Muslim brothers who were
recently killed out there for him along
mercy on them so a lot of different
things going on different hate crimes
out of things on that perspective but
also a lot of good things as well you
know with Canada welcoming with open
arms different you know refugees and
really setting the example of love for
people so you know how many lorries do a
lot of things you know were happening it
just depends on what we choose to focus
on now that was a in Fort Wayne Indiana
that was the three young men who got
killed execution-style was that one
right yes yeah there's any any new
developments on that and they catch
anybody I haven't really seen I mean it
hasn't been a well-publicized throughout
the media so I haven't seen made much
updates regarding it yeah and we're
starting to see that I mean this is this
is something that's on the rise
obviously do you think have they seen
that this has anything to do with hate
being a hate crime would you are they
going in that direction
well it's funny because with my
experiences America has a love hate
relationship with what they want to
consider a hate crime just like what
they would like to consider terrorism
you know we know that there's a serious
double standard so obviously you know to
those of us who
he can evaluate a situation objectively
it looks like it's obviously you know
hate crime likely you know due to their
ethnicity and or or their religion of
being Muslims you know especially with
the climate that's been pushed today
sadly with the a lot of Trump supporters
if you will and a lot of the overt
bigotry and the days from the 50s and
60s kind of being played out on the
media I want to show you a clip I want
to ask you and get your feedback on this
we're gonna watch this clip real quick
but am i anymore if I'm not this and I
was literally sitting there and like
thinking about killing myself in an
exact second I'm like I'm nothing I'm
like what do I do anymore
and no one gives me anymore without this
and I'm now my question is what is your
take on this when you have somebody who
is probably the most popular woman in
the world
you know Ronda Rousey right yes yes now
she's looking to achieve great success
she's achieved it money she's achieved
fame stardom why would someone up you
you take a turn in life you have an
obstacle in your path you you you you
suffer some kind of calamity and whatnot
but what would you know you've achieved
what millions are looking up to you
they'd love to achieve you've achieved
that why would someone contemplate
suicide it's funny you mention that and
there could be a number of different
reasons but it all kind of boils down to
a dis feeling of hopelessness and I
remember when I was a juvenile I was a
teenager had thought about suicide
several different times and one of the
things is this emptiness inside for this
bigger purpose so even though you
mentioned money and fame and many of
these things that people look to achieve
these are all external things what if
that inner peace doesn't exist with you
then you're still missing something and
we know that that that's the biggest
piece of the puzzle to your life's
happiness is having that inner peace
where you actually generate that peace
you generate that love you generate
based upon the knowledge that something
is bigger and you're moving in that
direction of course we found that with
Islam that's what I want to focus on for
a little bit we're gonna take a break
and then we're going to
from here purpose you know when somebody
has purpose the difference you know the
whole world can be coming down on them
and you know that they might for a
moment be some of that hopelessness but
right there right back in it you know
and the suicide doesn't even cross their
mind and and why why is such a dramatic
dramatic difference here we have a lot
to talk about we're gonna be talking
more about this clip of Ronda Rousey
when we come back don't go anywhere
salam says love all mankind that's why
we're sharing this message because we
want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind gonna be here every
Friday God willing inshallah subscribe
right now and enjoy all of the content
that we're going to be putting out for
you thank you peace be with you
so Mike
back here on the Dean show and we just
saw that clip with what would probably
be with no exaggerating probably one of
the most popular women I don't know if
she still is but she was definitely
Ronda Rousey is that correct right top
of her career she's in movies and was I
think fast and furious and and that she
was out of endorsed not just the talk of
the town but talk of the world yeah
absolutely
maybe not in the Muslim world but they
didn't do bi know she was okay so okay
so all over the world but now you have
someone who's achieved that people look
up to her people with the reason you
know a lot of times okay what will bring
up a certain celebrity a certain star
because people shoot to be like them
right and now when we see someone who's
achieved the greatest height of stardom
of Fame of you know money prestige this
person at the end is thinking suicide
right look similar to Robin Williams who
took his life last year Abby made dozens
or possibly hundreds of movies as famous
for decades had all the money all these
things that people look towards but
sadly looking towards something that's
external you know I remember first
coming across Islam and not wanting to
have any parts of it you know I saw it
from the outside I had a perspective of
it but I was raised Christian so I
wasn't really interested in it but the
second time I came across I was facing
challenges in my life in my religion at
the time being Christian wasn't
satisfying that so I had that
hopelessness but I was open to something
and to look at people and stories that
we have even Christians would have in
their Bible we have a story of use of a
prophet Joseph who was locked away you
know for false allegation but he was
still locked up and still had an inner
peace or you had the story of Jonah or
you know I you if you will who was in
the belly of a fish you know hopeless
but still praying out to his lord of
these people who went through drastic
situations and circumstances many times
we don't recognize that it's the
circumstances and challenges that shape
us when we look at meadow and what
metalsmiths the metallurgist have to go
through to really create iron or
different swords or different things
that are strong
they have to go through the fire really
have to to be cleaned and fill it in
order to come out the other side so when
looking at Rhonda Rousey to having all
this stuff is just like having many
other celebrities whether they look to
feel their their void or their gap with
alcohol or different drugs or different
addictions you know some people have
that hopelessness and look at you know
mice will end it all only because they
have this for false conception thinking
that well I'm just gonna go to dirt or
I'll just go to sleep as though there's
nothing after this life and and that
feeling really gets pushed a lot by what
we see in front of us every day when
people say are you successful or
successful
generally they're talking about
financial success so they're looking at
the things and the materials that it can
buy you as opposed to are you successful
with your health are you successful with
your your mental stability are you
sister successful in understanding your
purpose you know and the the bigger
picture of thing because we're all going
to die we're all gonna die we all have
questions about what's going to happen
after this life but having the proper
answers to those questions is what
separates those who know obviously those
who don't know for those who have hope
and those who are hopeless isn't that
what should be the fundamental question
for every human being where did I come
from
why am I here where am I going when I
die I remember having a second grade I
asked my teacher of mr. Worley at the
time because she was doing the class and
I was raised in Christian school and I
remember just sitting there you know
what was before this you know before my
parents gave birth to me how was the
universe it was obviously still going on
and I'm like 7 years old at the time and
asked that question like why am I here
what's the purpose what am I supposed to
because there was a time and I wasn't
here and of course what's coming so
those three questions
I remember beginning asking myself in
second grade of course I didn't get the
answer until I was a teenager and they
discovered Islam but without those
there's an emptiness it's like a puzzle
and this is that heart of the puzzle and
at least that's how I feel you know many
people that I know that I've accepted
Islam or that come to it understand the
peace the inner peace that comes with it
because no matter all of the other
things they're just things the things
that stimulates your you visually or
your senses but what is it that it does
for your heart you know that's that's a
major question that many
celebrities can't would you say you're
only as strong is what you actually you
you live for you live for this human
being let's say you're in a relationship
and then that relationship comes to an
end crushing people end up wanting to
kill themselves there's all hope is lost
you have a certain position you have a
certain amount of money people jumping
off buildings because they've lost let's
say they had a million they lost a few
million of that let's say 50% of they
still got another 500 million and these
are true stories people I mean jumping
off buildings because it is what
recently is funny cuz I think it was
maybe three four days ago when an
executive from Oklahoma an oil exec
and really bringing shale oil about was
with the Oklahoma City Thunder he was
instrumental in that own up maybe 20% of
the scene he just recently killed
himself he was charged by the Department
of Justice with fraud okay and doing
leases oil leases and stuff like that in
Oklahoma took his car or SUV ran it
right into a wall killed himself the day
after he was actually charged you know
this feeling of hopelessness or being
exposed as a fraud not knowing that
there's something after this life and
again you know I'm grateful to be able
to found that within Islam that answers
all of these questions and gives you
something to look forward to and much
more so something to work towards in
this life to prepare for the ones that
come and the statistics don't lie if you
look at the countries where people have
gone the furthest away from belief in
the Creator these are places they have
the most suicide rates right and this
tells you something I mean this tells
you when human beings not I mean
obviously living what you've been
created to live for there's always going
to be that void indeed it's funny
because PBS just recently did I don't
remember the name of the show there was
a study that talked about people that
believe in God or a higher power not
only have more peaceful lives in and of
themselves
but they live more purposeful life so
they give more in charity you no matter
how much they earn as usually those who
earn little that give more because they
give a larger percentage but because
they're looking towards something no
matter what the religion but knowing
that there's a God
think bigger allows them to live better
and have more hope and I remember a
quote with one of my mentors to always
say you know when there's no faith in
the future then there's no hope in the
present we're gonna go ahead and
continue on this topic about purpose we
were talking about we took off Ronda
Rousey an example of someone who's made
it to the top right and we want to give
her hope some hope
indeed hopefully because you never know
she might be actually tuning in to the
Deen show we'll be right back with more
don't go anywhere salam says love all
mankind that's why we're sharing this
message because we want the best for you
and we want the best for all mankind
gonna be here every Friday God willing
inshallah subscribe right now and enjoy
all of the content that we're gonna be
putting out for you thank you
peace be with you so now Mike
welcome back to the Dean show and we
kind of went in this direction after
watching the clip of Ronda Rousey who
was at the pinnacle of her career she
suffered a defeat probably never saw
that coming all right
Eagle takes over and then you kind of
just end up thinking you're unstoppable
self-sufficient you forget about you
chase all these material things and you
forget about your true purpose
reflecting about purpose you think
you're unstoppable then the person gets
brought down to reality it's a they get
humbled indeed and some people change
for the better
other people just they don't learn a
lesson what do you what are your
thoughts this is got a part of the human
psychology sometimes we get built up so
much that we created an alter ego when
you look at the story of faroan or
Pharaoh and he drew called himself a god
knowing obviously he wasn't but building
himself up and having those people
around you that don't remind you of the
good and remind you of your ultimate
demise whether it be Michael Jordan
being the greatest basketball player of
all time and you have a young Mike Tyson
or you have Muhammad Ali all of them
have their time and all of us are weak
and we all know we're going to die but
to have that reminder many of us we
don't like to think about death or we
might not have our wills done and you
know we are optimistic when it comes to
things we should be really serious about
and concerned about and realistic about
so it's part of human psychology to kind
of stay away from those negative
emotions but when you're thrust in it
again some people turn to alcohol or
drugs or other addictions or some you
know just feel hopeless and want to end
it all because they don't have something
to pull and to pray to where to pull and
get closer to to give them some type of
perspective sometimes these are the best
times when someone's at a humble state
they realized that they aren't
unstoppable that there are more
important things to life they suffer a
loss like this in their lives they might
be thinking so what do you like to tell
someone if you had a opportunity to talk
to someone like Ronda Rousey you know
and to really get them to to reflect
more not about fame celebrity status
money material things but to
motivate someone to think about purpose
why are you hearing this life and you
know definitely when you die you're
going somewhere after you leave indeed
well I really look at them two
perspectives one is to learn life and
children because there was a time when
you trying to learn how to walk you
wobbled you fell down cried you got back
up you kept on going so being persistent
and failing is a part of learning you
know what was about learning or played
with a new computer program is really
just learning the new computer program
what we learn about our playing and
getting involved with it and just like
all fighters know you know you're not
you're going to get hit and it's moving
forward I mean it's that old Chinese
proverb that says you know falling down
seven times get of eight so we know
these things that we know to be
consistent but know that everybody who
was at the top no they didn't just stay
at the top they all came down you know
this is normal
human history can be summed up in two
words you know a struggle in progress so
we have to have that in our lives so we
must honor that struggle whether we're
honoring it growing up as little
children or they're honoring it in a
career or in a relationship in marriage
or parenting or whatever we must honor
that struggle on those challenges
because it helps us get better for
example less than three days ago I was
getting off a plane and can you imagine
being on a plane with a brand-new pilot
that hits turbulence and loses his mind
that doesn't have some experience in
turbulence or do you want to be with the
pilot that has been through turbulence
before knows how to bring it down you
know certain feet to a clear area how to
avoid a storm how to work its way
through a storm you know so when
something happens you know what to do
you have some type of experience then
that's how we're built as humans we come
in here knowing nothing already
pre-programmed but we need to keep it
going and honor that struggle the second
thing is obviously asking those
questions are reflecting on it you know
I always tell people listen no matter
what your belief system is if you have a
belief system you know give yourself the
asset test study study the books study
all books study all religious study what
not study and get into its core because
when you get to the core you're seeking
truth you know realistically and
truthfully then I believe your your mind
your heart will be opened up to the
truth but always be open to it
I'm a Muslim so I'm gonna fight the acid
test I have the Quran I know it's a
perfect book no if there's one error in
it I would have to put it down and
disbelieve in it even though I believed
in the book before it had numerous
errors in it but once it was open my
eyes were open till my heart was open to
it but I was led to his son you came
from a Christian background correct yes
yes I was Christian Christian school I
know the Bible thoroughly I know Jesus
never said I'm God he never said I'm son
of God he never said where should be
none of this you said you know son of
man my father your father my lord your
Lord you know and I questioned this and
then I looked at Paul who never met him
who used to kill people that follow what
he taught you know when he was Saul of
Tarsus he never met him he had a vision
all of sudden he wrote 80% of the New
Testament and that hit me because I'm
like this person never met him you know
wrote this and he actually had fallouts
with the true actual disciples of Jesus
so I'm you know I'm picturing things out
and I suggest people picture things like
a movie in your mind when you're reading
something or when you're studying
picture that events yeah the technology
differently when I have cameras and
computers and all of that but the
interactions were the same the
relationships were the same the needs of
humans - and 3,000 years ago or the same
that they are today you know you want
love and to have intimate relationships
you want to procreate you want to
communicate all of these things are the
same so the difference is technology if
you take the technology out and you're
on a study for truth you know it's my
opinion you will come to the truth if
you're honest with yourself if you're
open to all of the possibilities and
then use your mind to differentiate
what's true was not you know I had to do
that I disowned all organized religion I
believe there was a guy I study ancient
African commit religions I studied
Judaism of course Christianity Hindu
Buddhism I said all of this stuff and
then when it came to this shorts order
of Quran sort of to the class you know
very short sort of then I said not
believe this is simple it's to the point
is deep I understand this now it's the
same short chapter of Quran that my
father had read in translation he said
you know I believe in this why looking
at a book with a medida Rahim a hula so
if your honor
genuine search and you're truthful with
yourself believe you will ultimately be
led to Islam and one of the things some
people try to do is try to do
I study the Quran or study Islam because
they say you know if I have an excuse if
I know nothing of it but doing that is
just trying to fool yourself you won't
enter peace you want to know who your
Creator is you don't need an
intermediary between you two or an
intercessor between you you know go to
the one who created you put you in your
woman took put you in your mother's womb
took care of you they brought you out
here into this life gave you a healthy
mind and body to work with in order to
move to the next transition after this
life once these answers I've met just by
speaking on my own you get a piece that
nothing can come in between because you
know we're going to die that reminder is
your mind to do what you can now with
what you have now because Yolo is a joke
you don't only live once no you only die
once
so as Yoda all right so you know that's
what I would definitely suggest and
that's what I suggest appearance that's
what I suggest to different teachers and
people that work with children in
particular because they're geniuses and
many times we kind of put them in a
small box and we want them to live with
full engagement and with joy we got 30
seconds left
tell us where people can get a hold of
you also run a parenting yes I'm a
parenting coach at outstanding Muslim
parents calm so which we outstanding
Muslim parents calm you could you know
find me we do different workshops
different speaking engagements we train
and teach parents really how to be
outstanding because we believe averages
nothing but the top of the bottom or the
bottom of the top you know sweet so for
example I do have the books I'll share
with your audience
Muslims parenting on purpose that we
written for parents just to really raise
the children up and understanding our
Islamic culture we also do different
programs a to DVD program or online
program called outstanding parenting
fundamentals 101 workshop and a CD
program and a six week at home study
course as well so you know come see me
at our standing most appearance calm or
invite me to your community you'd
definitely be a pleasure to speak with
the Michelle thank you very much so I
got a salon oft Allah peace be with you
an immersive Allah and thank you for
turning into the Deen show purpose why
you been created where did you come from
why are you here and where are you going
with when you did I very fundamental
questions which we get sidetracked we
get sidetracked with money with fame
with family with a
thousand one different purposes but we
forget to reflect on what is the true
purpose of life there has to be a
creator the one who designed all of this
that's just logic it makes sense and who
best to tell us and why we've been
created so it is befits you behooves you
to ask within yourself why have I been
created and then seek out the truth and
if you seek then you shall find but if
you're seeking to find that happiness
and money and fame and power it's never
gonna happen and then at the end you're
gonna end up losing hope and you can see
an example from our sister and humanity
the road that someone takes but there's
always hope if she's tuning in now is
the time to make a change for the better
and hopefully God willing it could be
made clear as it has been for many who
have sought to know and we'll see you
next time subscribe if you haven't
already until then peace be with you and
I'll be cool Salaam says love all
mankind that's why we're sharing this
message because we want the best for you
and we want the best for all mankind
we'll see you next time
God willing under D so continue to tune
in peace be on to you please subscribe
to the D show follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
you